[Music]
did you all uh enjoy the super bowl
yesterday did you enjoy it
did you enjoy the super bowl i did i i
liked it
well that's our show yeah
no it was i don't i didn't have a stake
in either team winning and it was just a
really enjoyable well i did i know
[Laughter]
last night the new england patriots lost
to the new york giants in a heartbreaker
yeah
yeah people from boston haven't been
this angry and depressed since every
other day of their lives
trust me on that one
tough town i called my family a day
before and they were pissed off
[Laughter]
what do you guys think of madonna's
halftime show did you like it
okay
that was uh that was about 1 8 of you
enjoyed it
madonna's halftime show featured roman
soldiers choir singers a marching band
an acrobatic tightrope walker and a
cleopatra outfit
yeah which explains why today lady gaga
held a press conference and said [ __ ]
it is on
[Applause]
you know what i'm talking about there
huh yeah i don't know what i just did
some sort of defensive lactating it
looked like
i learned that
if anyone attacks i just lactate it yeah
it works every time you gotta throw them
off that's for sure exactly
uh rapper m.i.a caused some controversy
at the halftime show did you see that
yeah today nbc apologized for rapper mia
giving the middle finger during the
halftime show nbc called the gesture
obscene and inappropriate
yeah then nbc said now stay tuned for
fear factor where a contestant eats a
monkey's ass
so now
[Music]
[Applause]
monkey's still alive you see
then what's he complaining about yeah
[Music]
i bow to you
uh tough loss for tom brady though last
night yeah last night tom brady's wife
did you this supermodel gisele bundchen
blamed the patriot super bowl loss on
brady's receivers
yeah then today giselle apologized said
i'm a little cranky because i haven't
eaten since 1994.
the monkey's like
i'm good